At this point it would be useful to touch upon some LOD settings you might be able to
get access to in your foliage.
So foliage does not support the use of level of detail or LOD meshes but there are a few
other restrictions.
So you should ensure that your static mesh has only one entry in the elements array which
is visible under log zero.
So that's the first step, make sure your static mesh only has one entry in the elements array
under the LOD.
The light and shadow maps are shared between all LOD levels so LODs need to use the same
unwrapping on their UVs.
So currently the entire cluster of instances change LODs simultaneously.
So there may be support for distance based fading per instance in the future but it's
not currently supported.
So lightmap coordinate index must be set to a valid UV channel that has a unique UV unwrapping.
The static mesh editors generate UVs feature is an option here where you could just use
in the static mesh editor window you can generate unique UVs and that will allow you to access
the window from the window menu and quickly generate some unwrapping there.
With the lightmap resolution this must be a small enough number so that all the shadow
maps and for instances in a single cluster can be tiled together without exceeding the
maximum texture resolution which is 1496 by 1496.
So the shadow maps must be considered there.
Again it depends if you're using a static solution or a fully dynamic global illumination
system like Lumen but again you're going to have to make these trade-offs and with all
LOD settings you need to make the trade-offs depending on what project you're working on.
And then to make the foliage fade you just need to use a per distance fade node like
this image here for a material setup.
So hopefully that gives you some good initial LOD settings to start thinking about when
working with foliage in your projects.